Spider-Man Spider-Man does whatever Tom
Holland can a lot of the acting in
Spider-Man wasn't really acting it was
just raw emotions and some serious
bromances number one with great power
comes even greater endings Aunt May's
final words were just downright
gut-wrenching it didn't take a lot to
get Tom into the scene because who
wouldn't be bawling about that with
great power but on top of all of that
Tom knew this might be the last time he
ever puts on the Spider-Man suit and the
thought of it rushed him filming this
scene just evoked that sense of the end
in him he said so you know thankfully I
was really able to draw on my own
experience and my own feelings in those
moments but this film also felt like a
huge celebration and he also found that
the relationship between Peter and may
was integral to the heart and soul of
the story so the end of May felt like
the end of Peter's Journey number two
what better way to test a superhero than
to to throw bread Zendaya throwing buns
at Andrew Garfield was most definitely
not scripted what better way to test if
someone is real than with bread you
wouldn't even need to throw it at us we
would gladly take a slice there was
something in the script that gave her
the inspiration though she was supposed
to grab a Candlestick and use it as a
weapon number three we all know that
Andrew is the sappy one I love you guys
this was another gem that was never
scripted and if you've seen a single
interview from Andrew Garfield you'll
know he's serious about his love for the
spiders
number four acting opposite your IRL
partner makes the mushy scenes a little
more palatable Tom Holland and Zendaya's
on-screen chemistry was hard to deny of
course they weren't doing much denying
either other than to fans and
interviewers for as long as possible but
even more than their comfort with each
other in the movies was their comfort
with each other in interviews dang is
Zendaya touchy and both of them are over
the top complementary of each other
number five yeah what about them Tom
Holland was genuinely confused about a
line from Alfred Molina so Tom is saying
to the villains I think I can fix you
and Molina improvised fix like a dog I
know I kept responding with like no why
would you fix a dog well all this can be
cleared up pretty simply the Brits don't
fix dogs they spay them and he was
confused about the Snipping he's like
why does he keep doing fixing a dog I
don't get it of course Molina is also
British but he spent a lot more time in
the states than Tom number six still the
best moment of the entire Trilogy saving
MJ was a very personal moment for Andrew
Garfield because of course his character
wasn't able to do that with Gwen Stacy
but it's about more than character when
his movie was canceled he was never able
to right that wrong and it kind of left
a hole in him it's no secret Spider-Man
was an obsession of his since before he
ever put on the suit and to not complete
that Arc was painful before even taking
on the role he was afraid he would be
used more like a prop or a gimmick but
when he saw he got to save MJ it sold
him on the project
number seven this tragic moment was
helped Along by genuine love that scene
on the rooftop where all of the
Spider-Man met was guided beautifully by
Tom who knew he had to feel the
emotional weight of the other two
Spider-Man but they also needed to
experience How Deeply affected he was so
he went up to them and said thank you
thank you thank you for doing this thank
you for being here thank you for
elevating Spider-Man in the ways that
you have thank you for being so gracious
and allowing me to share this with you
thank you for taking a leap of faith and
coming back so they all embraced each
other and just started crying because
these stories just meant the world to
them all and this Embrace inspired the
creative team to frame the characters
final goodbyes the same way it's hard to
believe they only filmed together for a
couple of weeks huh number eight the
ending Zendaya actually hated the finale
of no way home did you know that yeah
despised it she wanted a happily ever
after she wanted the characters to just
go to call Village so that ending her
bitterness was seeping into it just a
little it was kind of okay though right
because there's something not exactly
right between Peter and MJ and we can
sense that and she can sense that and
maybe we're reading into this too much
but like a true professional Zendaya
sucked back all the feels and just did
the scene seriously though what was that
ending
number nine the questions we all wanted
answers to were improvised that long
conversation the Spider-Man were having
while waiting for the world to crumble
was all just the actors messing around
only so much of their Ridiculousness
could be added to the movie but we're
sure there are more amazing gems just
waiting to be leaked one day the
question about where Toby Maguire shoots
his web from classic improvising
nonsense
number 10 how could they do Marissa
dirty like that we will gladly accept
zombie may we don't think Marissa Tomei
was ready to leave the MCU we still
would have rather seen her become a
superhero and kick butt she just
couldn't keep all the details of the
movie to herself the whole thing was
such an emotional roller coaster she
ended up telling her therapist about the
ending under oath number 11. Tom Holland
had the weight of the world on his
shoulders in this scene the scene in the
rubble in homecoming was a huge one for
Kevin feige he felt that was the moment
that was missing in all of the previous
Spider-Man movies the moment where the
character really comes into his own and
becomes the hero he was meant to be well
this was one of the most intense scenes
for Holland to film as well and you
can't really say that he was acting
because he was genuinely trapped beneath
heavy debris otherwise the metaphorical
weight of the scene would be lost it had
to be real the character had to be at
the ultimate low in order to rise from
the rubble it was incredibly taxing on
Tom to be trapped beneath it but he
managed he survived and Cinema thanks
him for it number 12. we are still not
ready to let go of Spidey even if he did
come back as Peter Parker slowly turned
to dust in Tony Stark's arms you may
recall him saying in a fit of tears I
don't want to go I don't want to go I
don't want to go he said it over and
over and over again and well it was
improvised humble Tom doesn't think much
of the Improv as it was the truth and it
was just one line it wasn't spectacular
in his mind but here's the thing
Perfection doesn't demand more than what
is necessary turns out four words on
repeat is a beautiful way to show
someone's fear of the unknown number 13
Toms Brewing around a lot we can't help
but notice before there was the
three-way Spider-Man Bromance Tom
Holland and Jake Gyllenhaal's immediate
and intense Bromance actually sparked
some script changes originally Mysterio
wasn't going to be half as chummy with
Tom but the softness that the two really
brought made that big reveal hurt so
much more number 14 like Father Figure
like sun figure RDJ and Tom Holland
awkwardly hugging in the car has become
pretty iconic and for good reason that
moment was never meant to be a hug truly
the awkwardness that came with that hug
was all on Tom thinking it would be
funny for Peter to hug Tony in that
moment and Tony's reaction is everything
we could expect and more from RDJ pure
and total discomfort yep number 15
there's nothing worse than being on the
spot when the camera is rolling poor
Jacob battle on was kept out of the loop
on what he was about to walk in on so
when he saw that MJ was in the same room
as Peter who was casually sliding into
the night monkey suit and far from home
he was forced to improvise it's kind of
a cruel thing to do to the guy but it
did get great results
it's hard to believe it's coming up on a
year since we saw our favorite Spidey
swing into action together and still no
real evidence of a fourth film are you
still holding out hope for a happily
ever after for Peter and MJ let us know
in the comments and thanks for hanging
out with us here at the things
foreign